do you know that Matthew Mark Luke and
John didn't write it all right okay I'll
explain to you why because the inil you
mean you you believe that the Revelation
that came to Jesus was written down by
Matthew M Luke and John how do you know
that they didn't write it that's the
question can I please uh was Matthew
Mark Luke and John oh so you're saying
now that what they've copied is from the
inel I'm asking how do you know that
Matthew Mark luk and John didn't write
it because okay what we so what he how
do you know that the inil was not a
biography
[Music]
rsy
God
God was the Revelation given to Jesus
the gospel given to Jesus was it a
physical book yes or no I can't tell you
that what do you mean you can't tell me
what is it okay hold on when when you
say physical when it was revealed did it
come down in the form of a book grabbed
with did he have imprinted into his mind
and then he spoke it and then they wrote
it down or he wrote it down so which one
is it I can't go definitive I'm I'm
sorry I'm sorry Cowboy which are you
asking me which one or are you telling
me which ask me which one you're
referring to yeah so I'm asking you when
when when it says
revealed means it came down from the sky
as a book that was already printed on it
it came from something that had to
printer and whatever it was made of
whatever and it was printed on these
papers or papus or animal skins or
whatever and he grabbed it and this was
the India yeah
is that's what I'm asking is that what
was given to him or was it something
that was simply oral no this is not how
not not simply oral this is how all
Revelation came is that it was revealed
to the prophets given to them all at one
time except for the Quran which was
given over a period of 23 years and then
they would recite it to their Companions
and they would write it down with their
own hands beautiful thank you so much so
Jesus did not have a physical a physical
Revelation a physical gospel no no no no
that's not what he said yes he did no he
didn't qu okay all right let me ask come
down in the form of a physical book like
it was floating in the air and gra let
me just ask it so just for we can get
clarification here did GE was Jesus
walking around with a physical gospel
yes or
no we're not told as far as I'm aware
we're not told as far as I'm aware
posible that he wrote it we do know
prophets before Jesus wrote their
gospels there there's aware of that says
that Jesus wrote his gospel and was
holding on to it as he was writing it
because all of the prophets knew their
their their uh Revelation by heart good
so no evidence that Jesus wrote that
Jesus wrote a physical gospel and was
walking around no one's claiming that
okay he did no we're not claiming it he
wrote we're saying it's possible this is
irrelevant red I didn't claim I didn't
make it logic this is reding can you
stop withal you did so I still not I'm
still not clear on the answer did he or
did he or did he not have a physical
gospel with answer that Avery are you
you wearing under that hat
you hold on hold on Avery
Avery we do not affirm nor do we deny
because there's not enough information
to make a determination whether he had
it written down or whether he was
speaking it to his companions either one
of those it doesn't matter to us because
he was teaching them Revelation no
matter
what that's our that's our position rsy
rsy what do you have to
say wait let me just finish
this in front of you 3800 people I said
that for a point I said that for a point
H what was your point what was your
point so you don't know you don't know
what theel was you don't know you don't
know if it was phys a physical reation
or not that Jesus the same thing that's
the same thing what you just said well
yeah so you don't you don't know so it's
the same thing I'm I'm laying out the
details of how no you're not you're not
you're deliberately I'm actually I'm
layer I'm layering what you don't know
no layer I'll make it easy for you we
don't know whether or not the inil was
in a book form or whether it's just oral
and and people wrote it as he spoke we
don't know
this to repeat all right here's my
question now was the inel written yes we
believe it was written down who wrote it
we don't know how do you know that
Matthew Mark Luke and John didn't write
it all right okay I'll explain to you
why because the inel you mean you you
believe that the Revelation that came to
Jesus was written down by Matthew M Luke
and John how do you know that they
didn't write it that's the
question can I can I please can I please
uh was Matthew Mark Luke and John oh so
you're saying now that what they've
copied is from the inel I'm asking how
do you know that Matthew Mark Luke and
John didn't write
it because
okay what we so what he's saying is that
how do you know not I'm not saying
Matthew Mark and Luke John the gospels
known as or written by Matthew martinl
and John how do you know these are not
eyewitness accounts and then that's not
the question that's not the question of
how how know aren't highness accounts
the question is how do you know that
they didn't write the Gospel because you
guys don't know who wrote the Gospel so
it doesn't have to be written it doesn't
have to be written don't know who wrot
wait let me let me land this doesn't
have to be written by eyewitness
accounts because you guys don't know if
it was written by eyewitness accounts or
secondary or third or we're saying we
don't know which we're not GNA say when
we say we don't know that means we don't
know the name of the companion if Jesus
himself wrote it or if he had a scribe
who wrote it that's what we're saying
we're saying we're not going to go out
on a limb and make a affirmative
statement without knowledge uhuh that's
what we're
saying you can learn that the gopel
100% if it was written which we know it
was because it read some other people it
was either written
by or by his companions but from who it
was we don't know was it him was it a
combination was it all of them one
second
so it was revealed so how how do you
know that Matthew I'll explain to exp
I'll explain to you because Matthew M
Lage on our biography how do you know
that it wasn't a biography how do you
don't know biography it is a biography
it is a biography how how do you know
that the inil was not a
biography rsy theil is teachings okay
very simple biy is biography of events
that happen later would not be what is
revealed how could events happen later
be the thing that was R second okay guys
one second one second one
second give an examp I'm example I'm gon
Give an example
crazy take me off the screen I don't
full screen I want have talk to Hamza
say something Hamza Hamza
do you believe in what was revealed to
the prophet Muhammad I do believe what
beautiful do we have biographies of the
Prophet Muhammad we do was this
biography of the Prophet Muhammad given
to the prophet Muhammad no does it
contain some things perhaps the prophet
Muhammad may have said well he did say
but yes he may have said does yeah it
does good beautiful right would I be
intelligent or would I be a boneheaded
buffoon to claim to think that maybe
peace be upon him was given this
biography of Muhammad peace be upon Him
ridic I I just don't get Avery Avery
Avery Avery how many times we have to
chop you for God's sake you're
embarrassing yourself AB you're you're
embarrassing yourself right for God's
sake I interrup you I interrupt you what
you say second one second Avery what are
you wearing under your hat seriously
what are you wearing under your for
God's sake so a I'm gonna ask you a
question was the Gospel of John given to
Jesus I'm G I'm gonna respond to that
well was the Gospel of John given to
Jesus I'm respond to that answer the
question was the Gospel of John to Jesus
I let him was the Gospel of John I'm
pulling I'm pulling I'm pulling the same
thing on you was the Gospel of
John goel of John given to Jesus he
responded but he didn't ask a question
he hasn't ask a question well just
answer this question and I'll give you R
don't Ry do you know the contents of the
NG what's in it you're asking me
questions now you're G resp I hold on I
can't ask you a question you can ask
question I'm challenging you I'm ask you
refuse to answer question arum make AR
yeah get man you're a waste of time so
so so this is what uh Ry just
did not responding to anything let me
finish please I gave you the opportunity
to respond I literally addressing your
argument don't ask me question AR love
relax so R just made a false
equivocation let him answer so I you can
ask your question he'll answer it after
he talks so Ramsey what you did was and
and you don't know this you actually do
this all the time you talk too fast but
you don't know the fallacies you make
you you embarrassing you embarassing you
made a false equivalence you're
embarrassing yourself you're humiliating
yourself you brought up a biography of
of Muhammad right biography of Muhammad
when you have information of the Quran
you know what the Quran is somewhat it
depends on what what sect you're asking
and what what Hadith you go to U it
depends on if you ask I massud or you
know I don't know who you ask but you
have an idea what
you have an idea of what the Quran is
you have an idea of the contents of the
Quran right but what you don't have is
you do not have this information about
the gospel that Jesus was going around
preaching you do not have this
information you do not know who wrote it
you do not know the contents of what
they wrote just ref what anything I said
let me finish please no I'm not I'm
actually refuting you I'm showing you
how you falsely made a false equivalence
here so you know the Contex of the Quran
you have an idea of it you have an idea
of the Contex of the Quran and you
actually know actually know that the
Quran is not a biography of of Muhammad
you know that but what you don't know
guess what what you don't know ramsy
what you don't know is what the gospel
is you don't know the contents of it so
you don't know if it was a biography of
Jesus and that actually was the
Revelation you don't know so hold on CA
I'm going to respond to I'm going to
respond resp let stay in there stay in
there stop trying to jump out the pot
stay in there so because you don't know
the contents of the NGO you don't know
who wrote it you don't know what it was
when it was where it was you can't tell
me that it wasn't an a biography when
you don't know that you don't have an
idea of the content so what you need to
do if you know that it wasn't a
biography show me the ngel and prove to
me that it wasn't a biography show it to
me beautiful beautiful can I can I can I
can I sure you stay in here make sure
you
don't don't try to jump out watch this
watch this ham ham let me ask you Hamza
Hamza if I go up to a non-muslim who's
never read the Quran before and I give
him this biography of the Prophet
Muhammad what would he automatically
assume that this biography about the
prophet Muhammad he's never read the
Quran he's never touched the Quran he's
never read the Quran maybe he's never
heard of the Quran if I hand any Tom
Dick and Harry who has an ounce of of
brain matter in their head a biography
about the Prophet
Muhammad would they ever in their right
mind say that this was a revelation
given to the prophet
Muhammad no no one would ever say that
you don't even if you've never touched
the Quran even if you never read the
Quran which I know you haven't Avery
even if someone has never touched the
Quran never read the Quran doesn't never
even heard about the Quran no human
being in their sane mind you are a
trinitarian though so it makes sense but
no human being in their s mind would
ever pick a pick up a biography but of
an individual and say that this is
something given to the individual it
talks about this person's life in the
future this happened this thing happened
that happened they died at this time
they died at that time they died at that
time this thing happened to them you
would never in your right mind I don't
know what you've been sipping on I don't
know what you've been cooking you
poisoned yourself whatever you've been
cooking anyone with an ounce of brain
matter would never assume that a
biography given to an individual is a
revelation given sorry what you call it
a biography of an individual was a
revelation given to the individual you
would never assume that so now Aver I'm
gonna ask you a question which you was
the Gospel of John given to Jesus so
what he did was again guys he made
another false equivalence he said if I
show any answering the question mham not
answering the question he would answer
in his response let us see if he anwers
it if he doesn't then he won't answer it
yeah yeah yeah just let it go so he said
if uh if I show anybody this this
biography of Muhammad will they believe
that this is a revelation given to
Muhammad will they believe that this is
the same thing hold on a
second
Rumsey if anybody went and showed them
the biography that Matthew Mark Luke and
John wrote would they believe what would
they say it is now I'm not asking you
this is a rhetorical question I'm not
not asking you to answer this if anybody
went around with Matthew Mark Luke and
John and Christians in the audience
answer this for me Christians in the
audience answer if anyone went around
with the bi with with Jesus's biography
that Matthew Mark Luke and John wrote on
stage what would they what would they
say it is all of them would say this is
the revelation of God the inspired word
of God the Gospel of Jesus Christ so we
know what the gospel is everyone has an
idea of the contents of the gospel and
what these this bio the biographies that
Matthew Mark Luke and John wrote are the
are is the actual Gospel of Jesus but
you guys don't have an idea of this you
don't you don't know who wrote it you
know you've
already I said said he was gonna
answer everyone guys you didn't stop run
what was my question all the
people you had your you not finished Ry
ramsy hold on Avery were you not
finished I was no I wasn't finished I
wasn't close I wasn't go okay hurry up
hurry goad so I'm I'm G take my sweet
time man I can't overcook you I gotta
take my time man I gotta feed you all
just no I mean so so so if you were to
hand anyone the so-called biographies
that Matthew Mark luk and John wrote
everybody's gonna say that's the gospel
that's the gospel everyone in history
said that's the gospel majority that's
the
gospel wait oh but you just did this rsy
he just said I'm quit I'm I'm I'm Ry you
you're an absolute joke I just did
exactly what he did and he said that
that's a fallacy bro this is what you
just committed so I'm showing you how
dumb your argument is so if you're
saying that my argument is dumb right
now then hey hey I'm I should look here
you go here you go man take it take the
sh back man you since you just cooked
your remind me what
rem's argument no my I made I have to
ask him a question respond so his
argument is his argument is no one would
say that the Revelation given to a
person is an actual biography of the
person itself that's what he's saying my
question to you guys was how do you know
that how do you know that Allah didn't
reveal to Jesus a biography of Jesus you
don't know that that's number oh just
just saying it's ridiculous or that it
doesn't make and you just said something
about every every you didn't answer my
question let him answer my question
didn't
let okay here not even if it's a
ridiculous cuz that that could
be going consistent hold
on he's gonna answer question Avery is
that consistent with the Revelation that
was given before is the Revelation that
was given to previous prophets their
biography and the words that people who
never met them wrote about them is that
the consistent with re presumption that
you have I'll answer that in the middle
of this so the the previous scriptures
you have the prophet stories about them
in the Torah it contains the story of
Moses and he's and and the tor asking
you the Revelation given to the
prophet what
youah the book of Jeremiah that is the
word of God is uh you have Jeremiah's
story in there so yes you have the
inspired word of God in the previous
scriptures the scripture was about we're
saying word of God not inspired word of
God written by other people who ignoring
my
question what I was saying stop
interrupting anyway so you don't know if
it was AO if if Allah revealed an
autobiography or not now but here's
another thing though because no I'm
asking you consistent to what Revelation
was given to the prophets for example
what was given to Moses not what was
written about him by others can't even
do you know what was given to Moses
according to the Bible I can't even land
my plane you're helping ramsy man keep
him in the pot stop what was given to
Moses do you know what was given to
Moses Cowboy I have no problem engaging
with you I have no problem understand so
let let he's not answer question let me
hold on hold on I just want to know do
you believe what was given to Moses was
the books of other people written about
him or was he giving something in
particular what was he given as
Revelation from God on the mount Moses
wrote Deuteronomy Moses wrote
Deuteronomy Joshua finishing it Moses
wrote Genesis Exodus and Leviticus so I
answered what did he what was revealed
to God from him him from God answer your
question no no no what was revealed from
God to him Point you're interrup
according to exod you're you're you're
supposed to be moderating fairly here
you're not letting me finish bro
according to Exodus that's not what the
Bible say that's not what Joshua
finished okay so I'm going just go ahead
according to your own B I know Avery I'm
asking you according to the Bible what
was I told you I told you Cowboy I have
no problem engaging with you as long as
you let me finish my plane I have no
problem understand you finished you said
that which
was my son is avoiding I have no problem
engaging fairly let me finish cking the
potato jump out the PO
trying to bring him down trying to help
what was revealed from the most high to
Moses upon Him according to Exodus what
was revealed to Moses okay thank you was
do you believe it was what Joshua fin
Leviticus Deuteronomy
Exodus is that what was revealed I'll
answer that at on once I finish so in in
finishing my response to Ramsey and I'll
get to your question um Muslim Cowboy
finishing my response to Rumsey he said
the argument was dumb which is the
argument that he actually made
so the inil was written down they don't
know by who they don't know the cont you
can you support don't they don't know
they don't know who wrote it they don't
know the cont of it so they don't know
guys he's not answering my question why
you guys keep letting him get away me
finish so they
don't clar know if the content of theel
contain the biography of Jesus you don't
know that you didn't just do what Ramsey
did to me how it is you didn't just do
what Ramsey did to you you didn't he's
not answering my question Ramsey Ramsey
Ramsey you took him to school and then
he started talking about everyone will
agree this is the gospel and this is
revelation you guys Christians don't
believe that all Christians don't
believe that you know Bob the Builder
doesn't even believe it's all Revelation
so it's like I don't understand how he
think there a monolithic
Christians a monolithic Christians who
believe this since the beginning of
Christianity you do you believe do you
believe a revealed book from God Ramy
Ramy it'll come to your question do you
believe
from God contain error Hamza mistakes
Hamza trying to change the AR it doesn't
help do doesn't help do you or not
doesn't help help it does help it does
help saying it's ridiculous saying that
it's ridiculous that oh it couldn't be
all be because you just made a claim
because that would be ridiculous no
because you just made you made the claim
you no no no no you made the CLA how do
you know that the that was written was
not I'll explain I'll explain explain
you just said that every Christian if
you showed them the gospels of Matthew M
Luke and John will all be in agreement
that this was revealed to Jesus or this
is revealed Revelation yeah I said
revealed Revelation I didn't but all
Christians don't believe that they don't
believe that all Christians believe that
the gospel is the revelation of God all
they don't Matthew Mar John okay good no
they don't they don't so you said that
they don't Sentinel apologetics he does
not
believe bring bring the quotes up uh
okay Hamza Hamza Hamza list listen you
AC do you accept
by biography of Jesus do you do you
accept by no answer the question you
haven't by default you're avoiding my
question you bum no you've been
avoid do you accept that or not Ramsey
you're on timeout man let the men talk
do you accept that R show me shut up go
Ramy go Ram Aver I own you I own you one
more time question you have ran from the
fourth time one more time brothers and
sisters everyone watching all the fan
girls on his channel everyone listen
carefully I ask not once not twice
maybey Ry one more time stop TR stop
quiet stop manifesting get the the ho
Spirit out of you get the Holy Spirit
out of you the gopel of John was the
Gospel of John given to Jesus I'm
telling you I know it's difficult was
theel H man I know it's hot keep coping
was the Gospel of John Jes I know it's
was the Gospel of it to Jesus Avery yeah
we're gonna I want us to make some
progress before we go to
the understand I know I want to go to
the next Point I've been waiting forever
on because this is a debate review we're
supposed to be revie
debate agrees to this he knows that's
why he's here we were gonna talk about
the debate so I want to finish this
Avery you'll answer one of rumsey's
questions whatever question he has has
to answer Ry you'll answer one of his
questions whatever question he's IGN my
question for the past understand R for
us to move on I don't care how long it's
been he's gonna answer your question
whatever question is you'll answer one
of his questions
whatever you need to relax I gotta go
pray to the
god I need to go Avery I need to
go calm Ry we can move on one more time
one more time yeah problem try try again
go ahead try it again no
problem answer then Avery's gonna ask a
question question after he answers and
then you'll answer fine but he has to
make it quick I have to go worship the
God Jesus worshiped one one more time
very simple was the Gospel of John given
to Jesus okay so before you go and pray
to the god that Allah prayed to I gotta
help you out here so Accord according to
Ian Shak John's gospel answer the
question's gospel is the revelation of
Jesus according to Ian I'm not talking
you don't look like Ian ha you look like
Ian ha he
didn't you just said the same God that
Allah prayed to sec second is a mix of
one second one second Brandon Brandon
Brandon the gospel of what it call
what's it called IB is a mix of true and
false information I have no problem I
have no
problem that's not us that's
not that's one more time was the Gospel
of John given to Jesus according to iak
John's gospel is the revelation of Jesus
good to know was the Gospel says I'm
gonna go with your story good to know
was the Gospel of John given to Jes your
sour R he WR the Gospel of John given to
Jesus wrong Brandon is he answering
Brandon is he answer question I answered
you he has no according to you not I
is Avery was the Gospel of John given to
Jesus guys Hamza cried earlier that I
wasn't talking was the Gospel of John
given to
Jesus parad was the Gospel of John go
into Islamic paradig what
Y what we doing guys please please let
me speak you know this Avery shut up you
know this very well be quiet be
quiet Avery you know
wanted me to Islamic
paradig are crying that I'm staying
under
isad please let me finish Avery you know
well and your audience knows well ibonus
talk we don't take as a fully reliable
source of
information be quiet be quiet you know
this stop it stop I'm a Muslim I'm not a
Christian quiet they muted you're not
muted be quiet you're not mut quiet as a
Muslim I do not GL swallow anyone says
anyone says about my Prophet or about
anything IB isak you know well ask the
greatest of scholarship IB isak is in
fact he says this in his own title his
own introduction iban isak is a mix of
true and false information appealing to
I asak does not better your position it
does not worse in my position answer the
question does the gospel was the Gospel
of John he just let me just let me
answer you let me answer you because I
yes or yes or no was it to Jes respond
to you so guys was it given to Jesus you
you you just you just you just cooked
yourself because you don't you don't
have what we don't have guys we don't
have Ian as shak's original original uh
narration what we have is matters to my
point goel of John we're not asking
about IB ha let me make the point Ibis
hack is not a fully reliable source of
information the point we don't take
everything I thex says the point watch
this just we don't take everything from
you panic mod from in his hey guys watch
this watch this are you death them and
blind every see this everyone can see
your deflecting fear in his
face look at him everyone can see I'm
scared I'm scared look this I'm scared
I'm so scared look at this
scared one more time Avery gopel joh to
Jesus we do
not we do not take all the information
from
I this is Avery Avery can you answer it
yes or no can you
answer can you answer the question
who what he thought was
authentic removed everything he's not
fully authentic you keep appealing to IB
we don't take him as fully authentic we
don't take his right EX look at these
guys M me now look at them muting me
this is it let me make the point that I
was about to make this is why they
didn't this is why he ran away from iak
and tried to oh well what he says is now
h on us it's not authoritative on us we
some things are good some things are not
watch this guys we don't have any of Ian
as's original text we don't have it what
we do have is what Ian hasham his
student edited from The Works of iban
hashak okay now why is this important
because Ian hasham and he States this in
the book you guys can find this if you
get his book you get the book he States
it he says
he says that Iman aak had a lot of false
narrations and weak narrations in there
right that he included in his work so
Ian hasham says that he
removed what was not authentic he
removed what was
weak guess what he left in there ladies
and gentlemen because remember IB Hasam
is editing it that's what we have we
have IB asam's edited work of IB Ash's
work so guess what he left in there he
left in the part where Ian asak records
a story where Muhammad is talking about
the companions of Jesus and says that
John wrote the Gospel of
[Music]
Jesus he left that in there oh my God